[Musique]
c'est une première en ile de france un
centre propose de tester le karting
électrique à mes côtés emmanuel emmanuel
qui est propriétaire du centre pourquoi
avoir voulu tester le karting électrique
bonjour alors testé le kart électrique
parce que je pense que tout le monde
pense un peu électriques actuels à venir
pour moi ça ne l'est
c'est peut-être arrivé un petit peu tôt
puisque n'est effectivement unique en
ile de france
mais il fallait bien que quelqu'un fasse
le pari donc je les fais certains se
plaindront peut-être de ne plus hors de
bruit ni d'odeur mais on constate quand
même qu'il ya pas mal de personnes qui
adhèrent à cette nouvelle solution
quels sont les principaux changements en
termes de sensations de temps c'est la
notion d' accélération qui est plus plus
importante que son 1/4 thermique et on a
maintenant de la vitesse linéaire jusque
en bout de ligne droite
hyper intéressante bon je pense qu'on
peut se lancer
on va tester le karting électrique
[Musique]
première sensation ben c'est pas trop
mal on voit pas trop la différence avec
un karting classique sauf peut être à la
réaccélération et dans les virages il
faut vraiment vraiment faire attention
au frein parce qu'on peut vite déraper
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour cette session parce
que ça coûte cher ou pas un circuit
comme celui là et des kartings comme
cela alors un quart thermique va coûter
environ un peu moins de 6000 euros hors
taxes un kart électrique va coûter plus
de 15000 euros hors taxes on peut rouler
à partir de 12 euros
lorsqu'on a une carte club merci
beaucoup et je crois que je vais
reprendre quelques cours quand même je
vais revenir ici sur circuit pour
m'entraîner
[Musique]